I mean what do you mean frogs are
becoming gay for instance you say well
the water they haven't liked ever when I
was in the Army and they would say with
the punch they put in the army that you
drink it it's purposely set up so you
don't get too excited to want to have
sex because when you're in boot camp and
AIT you know they don't want you to be
too sexual because you're not gonna feed
the opposition so they got to tame you
down a little bit now that was a rumor
that we're saying that we'd say ok maybe
right maybe not right but I think you'll
take that and you'll say something like
well you know it's because you know
Clinton is tied to Nazi in Hitler and
and then you sell it even bigger here's
what I mean you get whatever when I have
500 Harvard reports guy about atrazine
causing low sperm counts then I cover it
then that's the big secret it's not I
think punch I don't go oh my god punch
yeah it's when I just turn to run and
you say the water they're feeding us as
the water that they put into you know
frogs and not frogs are becoming gay
because they want our kids to be gay I
mean what do you mean frogs are becoming
gay well that's actually Bertrand
Russell on the UN they said we will add
chemicals to the water to confuse the
sexuality reduce population that's
official UNESCO plan have you read the
book naked communist like Leon Skousen
you know which one I'm talking about
I've read the I've read the naked
communist mmm read the naked capitalist
he wrote okay yeah I know I've seen
these these methods on what they want to
do to take away the original oh here's
the sperm count the general sperm counts
not about ninety percent in the West
yeah but the frogs what's the story with
frogs being gay with the water they got
you watch frog porn how do you wanna let
go you know I'm a huge fan of front no
no it's funny you say that like I love
frog porn tell me about this frog porn
you're talking about here frogs are
amphibians so they're in the major water
dump-off systems and like ten years ago
they had a show on Democracy Now
okay and they had one on PBS okay and I
played the reports how most the frogs
were asexual or we're trying to have sex
with other males and so frog populations
were going down 90% and I talked about
it the media attacked me and said Jones
is homophobic against gay frogs somebody
the joke I said oh my god they're
putting some of them in the water to
make the frigging frogs gay and they
took that out
anybody can search a democracy now
anybody can search PBS and so it becomes
this debate about Alex Jones instead of
the runoff is so toxic that our kids are
involved in the emasculation of man and
the it causes women breast cancer you
know all it really hurts people that it
becomes this big thing and I just sit
there and I just go okay I mean on the
biggest virzi theorist I I covered PBS
Democracy Now about their headline
Democracy Now was run off making frogs
gay so I was reading a Democracy Now
headline and ten years later no one
shows that remember to clip when you did
it you just said you know the returning
get you you were just speaking you you
were well I just played the clip yeah
and I said oh my god they're making the
frigging frogs game but I mean why would
you say something like that they're
making slugs so the chemicals aren't bad
it's it's me saying